you've got to be joking me hopkins
reaches up with three defenders around
him and
pulls it in and the cardinals lead it
32-30 with a second lap
you can't cover duke you're not gonna be
able to cover them
throw the ball off that's what kyler
murray did
you know in basketball terminology
that's what they call this
you know somebody get dunked on but it
was on three people
uh you know
yeah it was um you know they were they
were in position
it was just a better catch by deandre
hopkins is a
lead receiver in this league you know we
understood that we understood that
coming into the game we knew
uh what he was able to do and um
you know best hands in the league he
showed it right there um
i feel like we all possibly could you
know me personally i know i could have
time time's up better you know i was
trapped behind him i was too worried
about
him getting over top of the defense so i
stayed back
and tried to force everything to be in
front of me and then at the at that
same time you know when the ball was in
the air i just
i was stuck behind him i wasn't able to
get in front um and then he just times
it up better he went up first
and you know in a play like that it's
like basketball rebound whoever's
whoever's up first time is the best i
was able to bring it down
that ball literally just stuck to his
hands good throw by
murray and it just it just stuck to his
hands he was able to bring it down
was there anything that you think could
have been different other than the
outcome of the play
in how it was defended or could you have
done any better than that
i mean yeah of course i mean i mean
honestly
could i have done any better of course i
could have done better yeah i meant i
meant in terms of the
okay that that's what i was yeah there's
always that's that's why i said what i
said that when i came in here
very first question i said you're always
as a coach you always think about what
we
could have done differently that's the
very first thing i said
what could i have done differently what
could we have done differently right you
asked the players the same questions
we got great guys in this locker room
they're saying the same thing
knock the ball down you can't be
interception minded in that situation
knock the ball down
right so at the end of the day give them
the credit they made a special play
sean mcdermott a little salty there and
for good reason it's in the immediate
aftermath of a deflating loss a game
that they had
believed they'd won they got that
feeling that they're gonna win it they
just had to play some defense and
ultimately were unable to and peter you
spoke to kyle murray after the game at
length i had him for a few minutes look
murray had a ton of confidence when he
let go of the football he did a great
job getting away from a would-be tackler
to extend the play
through the ball he told me that when he
let it go he knew it had a chance of
course having andre hopkins there to
potentially catch it would increase the
confidence level
i still don't understand why the bills
didn't have more guys drop back i think
at some level you're concerned that kyla
murray is just going to rip right
through everybody and you're not going
to get him by the time he gets to the
end zone
because once it's time to go catch him
you may not be able to
but you have any sense why they they
didn't have more guys
back there trying to knock that ball
down
i really don't think that was the issue
mike because when you
when you think about it they either had
seven or eight people back okay
depending on how you see
the way the the the quarterback was
rushed on that play
and let me let me just say i think there
are three points
about this play that i find extremely
interesting okay did you see the quote
that i had from murray
about basically when he got up to the
line and he came out of the huddle
he called the play and he told me and i
quote
the play was kind of in shambles
okay so you know i couldn't quite figure
that out and he didn't really want to
say
exactly why the play was in shambles
but i think we can figure it out now
thanks to something
that peter schrager said on good morning
football
this morning and that is that
according to cliff kingsbury the first
read
for the quarterback on this play was a
drag route and so a drag route in this
particular case
is when a player runs is on the opposite
side of the field and he comes
all the way across the field maybe 15 to
20 yards deep down
field okay he comes all the way across
and you get the ball to him
and he runs out of bounds and you've got
two or three seconds left
and you got one more play maybe from the
25 yard line now it's not a hail mary
it's a real legitimate pass
this is why i think that
kyler murray called the play in the
huddle and without
any intention to ever look at andy
isabella
who was the the guy who was doing that
drag route across the middle
mike if you watch this play you see that
as
six turns to five on the clock
kyler murray got rid of the ball okay
and it comes down from the sky
at about three seconds to go it's caught
there's either two or one seconds to go
okay time out time the clock is stopped
right there
so just imagine for a second this is
what kyler murray
has to be thinking if i throw the ball
to andy isabella
and he can't immediately get out of
bounds if there's some traffic there
and there is standing between him and
the sidelines
the clock's going to run out so to me
i know what i'm going to do when i leave
the huddle
i am gonna wait until andre hopkins
deandre hopkins
gets in the end zone and i'm gonna throw
it up
and i'm gonna make him win a jump ball
now that's one thing
my second point though mike if you watch
very closely time and again i watched
this 30 times
watch tredavi is white at one point you
can see tredavius white
his two hands come together like he's
trying to catch the ball
okay the one rule for a defensive player
whether you punch it whether you slap
at it whatever it is that you do
you're not trying at all to catch the
ball
all you want to do is get the ball
out of the hands of the receiver that
is the fatal mistake by the buffalo
bills that
is why the buffalo bills only have a
one-half game lead
in the afc east today
are you suggesting mr king
that kyler murray went rogue did kyler
murray disregarded
the code red that he disregarded no
the way i mean i like it if it is
no i'm telling you what i am suggesting
and this is what
from what we know now if peter schrager
is correct
that the first read on that play is andy
isabel on a drag route but
but i know this is from
you know having talked a couple of times
to to murray
and and knowing the way that he's
coached by cliff kingsbury
cliff kingsbury does not have his thumb
on kyler murray
he does not say well you better do what
i say
he basically gives his quarterback the
power
because his quarterback's on the field
because i believe what he said to kyler
murray
and schrager uh you know referred to
this
is hey if you think the better play
is to deandre hopkins make it do it
so i don't even think when this ball was
in the air that cliff kingsbury was
saying
what is he doing i think cliff kingsbury
gives kyler murray the wherewithal to
make
a decision a huge decision at the line
of scrimmage or while he's rolling out
about what he should do
and that's the kind of coach i would
want too but
i sense that kyler murray just felt like
listen there's a 15 20 chance
if i throw this ball to andy isabella
and it's complete
we're not going to get another playoff
i'm just fascinated by the comment that
the play was in shambles i didn't
realize that was a
pre-snap observation i thought it was
something that he
had referred to after
a guy chases him he's got to break away
he's got to improvise
i didn't realize that was a pre-snap
thing and you're you know i love kyla
murray
and he's not your typical gregarious
quarterback he's a little shy
right and sometimes it's hard to draw
things out of him and that's okay that's
okay
uh but uh yeah sometimes there's
something left for interpretation and
regardless
it worked it worked for him it didn't
work for the buffalo bills
and i like the point about tridevious
white that's a coaching point for the
future hatred davious next time you're
in a hail mary situation
don't try to catch the freaking ball
knock it down
knock it down and knock it down i think
it blows me away mike it
one last thing it blows me away that
there are three players for the buffalo
bills and it's not like
it's wilt chamberlain versus bob cousy
or shall we say
shaquille o'neal o'neill versus mugsy
bogues
these guys are within three inches of
each other it's not they're not
it's not like deandre hopkins people
were making out like deandre hopkins got
a foot on these guys he does not
i mean those guys should somebody
should have been able to get a fist on
the corner of this ball
period and if you risk past interference
then you risk it
even though they never ever ever call
past interference on a hail mary
yeah uh somebody posted a tale of the
tape with deandre hopkins and the three
defensive backs
and i expected it to be much more
jarring than it was i looked at the
various numbers and i'm thinking
yeah i mean you're right it's not
shaquille o'neal and mugsy bogues
they had a shot to go up and at least
get a hand on the ball
and knock it away that's all they had to
do he needed to get two hands on the
ball and catch it
and somehow he did hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports